behind these walls some of the country's
most vulnerable children plagued by
allegations of abuse and mismanagement
privately run secure training centers
like rains brook in northamptonshire
have a dark history fifteen-year-old
Gareth Meyer died here in 2004 after
being restrained by three guards an
inquest found numerous failures in the
way the center was run contributors to
his death in May more than a decade
after Gareth myates death g4s finally
lost its contract to run this Center
inspectors have found staff high on
drugs and children suffering racist and
degrading treatment then in January
evidence emerged of abuse and neglect at
another g4s run center in medway g4s the
since decide to sell all its centers
that raises two questions first other
vulnerable troubled children inside here
being seen as business assets whose care
can be bought and sold and secondly who
will buy them
on the other side of the Atlantic adult
prisons attract their own controversy at
Mississippi's Walmart Grove an inmate
was dragged from his cell set upon by a
gang and then repeatedly beaten with
crates the ensuing violence is too
distressing to show in detail moments
later another inmates offers a sustained
attack security is nowhere to be seen
it's run by American company MTC it's
British offshoot MTC novo is the group
awarded the contract to take over reigns
Brook Walnut Grove in 2015 the federal
judge found that MTC had failed to take
adequate steps to protect the security
of the people inside it's disturbing the
MTC would be able to expand in the UK
given its record in the United States
the government insists allegations
against MTC in the US relate to the
period before the company began running
the prison's but a court document
describes an MTC facility in Mississippi
as an extraordinarily dangerous prison
with stabbings and assaults due to a
systemic failure to hire qualified
security staff and to adequately train
them and in November last year British
human rights groups raised concerns
about MTC novos track record claiming it
has no experience of running residential
establishments for vulnerable children
in response the Youth Justice Board said
it had assessed them rigorously and that
MTC novo met the Ministry of Justice
requirements in relation to capability
human rights and equalities MTC say they
inherited pre-existing problems in US
prisons which they've significantly
reduced for Leila and Ronnie it's
troubling they describe mistreatment at
medway where they were detained five
years ago any little thing elkin they'll
put you on the floor excuse my hands on
you they'll put their hands on you if
you'll refuse to go to bed within three
minutes they've got people on you that's
not right for child and for 15 years old
that's not right to be treated like that
who's going to believe you when you're
trying to basically put bad wording for
somebody in the system now I was going
to believe you you're just this violent
child runs going to believe what you say
I think if it's going to be run it
should be run by people that know how to
deal with children altogether I don't
because you get all kinds of children go
in there so much has gone wrong in
secure training centers that they're
under intense scrutiny while they'll
continue to be profitable the fear is
that it's young people who are paying
the price half wash Sky News